desperate for flower the government
announced there will be free
distribution of it for those in need and
Pakistan is in the middle of an economic
crisis inflation is at 40 percent basic
food prices have more than doubled while
wages have stayed the same it's the
worst economic crisis since the
country's Independence
prices have gone up by 300 percent
before a hundred dollars a month used to
be enough but now even if you get two
hundred dollars you need to borrow money
we can't buy flour sugar so many things
and that's why I'm here buying clothes
for my children we can't afford new ones
the delegating the horse stands as a
reminder of more affluent times during
the Mughal Empire a time before British
rules when this Region's output
accounted for nearly a quarter of the
world's economy the people passing
through it today are more focused on the
price of Basic Foods prices that
sometimes change overnight
the situation is very bad I curse those
that are running the country from last
week the price of flour has almost
doubled we don't want your free flower
just lower the prices pakistanis we
spoke to don't want handouts they want
stability and the government to control
the economy and food prices
[Music]
even getting one meal a day is very hard
my husband died a month ago I had to
take my two children out of school to
work the prices have gone up so much for
the poor it's unspeakably difficult
the nation is now importing more than
it's exporting and it and it's still
waiting for an international monetary
fund package but the IMF wants reforms
but some say the government needs to do
more
it's not just that you go to the
Americans or you go to the Saudi and
secretaries help us with the IMF they
now are associated look at all the
things that you've not done why are you
not doing your own job so we have to now
look at introspect and look through it
ourselves that what is it that we are
doing wrong what is it that we are doing
that so many pakistanis from Heber to
Karachi are folk the poor are not able
to get jobs or not able to make and
meets that are we done in this country
correctly or not an estimated 8 million
people are unemployed and Pakistan's
foreign currency reserves are only
enough for a month of imports when you
speak to people
in the children Act of school others put
off going to the doctors all to save
money to feed their families and with
the political turmoil in the country
there appears to be no end in sight for
those on the breadline Assad Bank Al
Jazeera Lahore Pakistan